the lines are not blurred in emily's
allegation that robin drunkenly groped
her on set of the controversial unrated
version of his 2013 music video
quote out of nowhere i felt a stranger's
hands cupping my bare breasts from
behind
[Music]
emily's allegation is in her upcoming
book my body in an excerpt obtained by
the sunday times of london emily writes
quote with that one gesture robin thicke
had reminded everyone i was nothing more
than the hired mannequin
for operating emily's account the
video's director diane martel who told
the times quote i screamed that's it the
shoot is over robin sheepishly
apologized i don't think he would have
done this had he been sober
vic has not commented on any of the
allegations
after the video was released robin
defended it when critics said it
glorified rape culture we didn't think
it would it would cause as much
controversy we thought of people you
know a few people would be like oh you
know boobs you know
but our intentions were so pure just to
have a good time
[Music]
you